i think it's very important for us to
follow the advice of the prophet sallam
which is you know the cure to ignorance
is to ask and learn and we shouldn't
basically have our own intellectual and
emotional baggage and superimpose it on
things that we don't understand once we
stand in that humble space
and that's a spiritual space to be in
once we stand in that space and we stand
in the possibility that maybe my
understanding of the quran or my
understanding of islam could be
completely wrong if you're in that space
then we're ready to roll
salaam alaikum
welcome back to the realest podcast in
the dunya the three muslims we're joined
here with brother hamza andreas zortsis
stay tuned for a live stream with him
it's going to be a live not pre-recorded
this friday that's tomorrow september
2nd 6 p.m eastern standard time
and right now we're going to give you a
little teaser what's to come
the quran is saying that sperm
is
cut originates from between the backbone
and
the ribs the rib cage this is that area
right there for those of you who can't
see that's a smaller image right there
this is where it supposes that sperm
originates now we know biology says that
your sperm comes from where your
testicles
if you were to remove your testicles you
will no longer be able to produce sperm
it again got nothing to do with what's
going on up here
can we all agree that this is the rib
cage
and this long thing coming from the neck
all the way down to the top of the um
pelvis is the backbone
and so what is in between these two
things if you were to draw a cross
section y'all remember doing venn
diagrams in math class it would be
somewhere around this area somewhere
around the long's heart
area
far cry from between the legs
so how did how did allah get such a very
simple thing of biology wrong
so
now i don't know the guy
but what i can assume from his
apparent presentation is that he's just
taking stuff
from the web without investigating
without analyzing without understanding
and for me what that presupposes
is a kind of psychological disposition
or a non-negotiable approach of i
already believe this is wrong
irrespective of the evidence
and whatever conforms to this
non-negotiable assumption
i'm just gonna grab it and i'm gonna
throw it out there
and unfortunately when someone does that
it's indicative of someone who's not
not willing to know the truth as the
truth
because he's clouded with certain
emotions i'm not saying this from a
judgmental perspective because i've
suffered this i still suffer this we all
human beings have have this issue right
that we're not just abstract intellects
or not ai machines but we have a
disposition and this is aligned with
islamic psychology as well
i'm just bringing it out there just to
show the audience that it's very
dangerous when you're talking about
religion when you talk about any ideas
when you talk about truth even in
abstraction
and to do it in a way that you don't
look at your sources you don't
investigate you don't ask questions you
don't come from a humble place you don't
come from a position of
trying to think
and this is very interesting because
what this gentleman is actually talking
about is basically chapter 86 verses
five to seven
when
allah says that man should reflect on
what he was created from he is created
from a spurting fluid
then he emerges from between the
backbone and the breastbone and then
allah says in the verse 8 allah or god
is certainly able to bring him back to
life so so this is very important if we
look at 86 8 this conclusion allah or
god is certainly able to bring him back
to life allah is giving us a epistemic
goal if you like which is a conclusion
that we must affirm as a result of what
allah has mentioned to us so the whole
theme here is god's power and ability
that he has maximal power and ability
and he is able to bring us back to life
after we die and if you look at the
whole chapter the theme of the chapter
is essentially resurrection and allah is
using the evidence of our emergence our
birth
and
our rebirth if you like in the arkham
brings us back to life he's using these
examples and these themes to reinforce
allah's power and the fact that he's
able to do these things and this is very
important to understand
from that perspective because when allah
in the quran talks about natural
phenomena generally speaking allah gives
us the epistemic goals meaning the
conclusion we must affirm
and allah tells us who we must be
in order to affirm that conclusion allah
talks about this
those who ask questions
allah talks about
using your brain your intellect right ya
to use your intellect
karuna those who reflect
the buruna those who ponder
those who have deep insight so we must
be people who use our intellect we ask
questions we want to look into the
interconnecting principles of nature and
find out what is the the great power and
wisdom behind all of this and so on and
so forth so we have to be in that state
but to be in that state you have to be
sincere
so allah has given us a conclusion here
talking about resurrection now what this
gentleman has done he's tried to show a
scientific error the the biggest blunder
he's done he's assuming the quran talks
about sperm nowhere in these verses does
allah talk about sperm
for example if you want to
relate to the concept of sperm in the
quran it would probably not and not
basically means
a
a minute or small portion of fluid from
a greater quantity okay
now allah doesn't mention this here he
mentions something totally different in
arabic he mentions fluid or water he
doesn't mention
so allah doesn't mention sperm from that
perspective so they've assumed that
allah is talking about sperm but in
reality allah is talking about the
gushing of spurting fluid so that's
number one error
the other error is that he thinks that
even
let's assume he's saying that fine okay
maybe he was talking about
fluid and not just the sperm the sperm
doesn't come from between the backbone
and the ribs because there are other
detractors online that talk about this
fine maybe god is not talking about the
sperm here because he doesn't use the
word mutfur he's using the arabic word
for fluid or water if you like
and and okay
that's fine but the issue here is that
it's it doesn't come from between the
the backbone and the breastbone and he
and as you see he showed some images now
here's a problem
if you study classical arabic you study
the multi-layered aspect of the quran
you would see that there are at least
three valid interpretations for this
verse and ready
the first interpretation is that it's a
gushing fluid okay and this is the
opinion of the classical exergy like ibm
cathedral and many others a gushing
fluid so even from a kind of scientific
perspective is this an error is this an
error does gushing fluid come from
between the the backbone and the
breastbone of the backbone or even the
ribs okay because if you look at the
words concerning backbone and ribs you
have for example
uh the word
which comes from the root
which means collarbone upper chest and
ribs so that is the kind of collarbone
and ribs then you have the other word
which indicates loin by also means
backbone
and it comes from the root sod
and what's very interesting that root
itself also means to become hard or
rigid which we're going to talk about
something in a few moments so
so there are multi-layered meanings with
these words so
if you take the view that it's the
backbone and the ribs well that's not
really a scientific error because 75 to
around 85 percent of the seminal the
sexual fluid
what spurts out of the penis
is actually it comes through the
seminal vesicles and the seminal
vesicles are above above the testicles
yes sperm may come from the testicles
but the majority of the fluid and a lot
talks about the fluid here not the sperm
the majority of the ejaculatory fluid
comes from the
vesicles and the seminal vesicles
uh if you like adjacent to a parallel to
the to the backbone from the definition
of what the backbone means
in the islamic tradition because the
backbone also includes the tailbone if
you like yeah
and the tailbone is in line with the
seminal vesicles and if you draw a line
you hit the ribs right so it's literally
between the backbone and the ribs now
you could take that view i'm not saying
this is the most accurate view but even
from a kind of poetic perspective
because you have to understand the quran
is a form of rhyme prose a unique form
of rhyme prose it's sadja as devin j
stewart he talks about a quranic form of
sahaja yoga it's a rhyme prose and
writing prose the defining feature of
rank pro has a concentrated use of
rhetorical devices so we're not talking
about a a scientific textbook or or or
text that is a straightforward language
it's a very rich language right
so you could take that view
and that view is not is not
scientifically wrong
the other view is and this is the view
of classical scholars such as
and and others and also modern scholars
like professor abdul haleem
and ahmed makki they basically say this
means the baby
so when allah talks about
and it and it comes from between the
backbone and the ribs this is actually
referring to the baby yes it can refer
to the fluid itself because of a
grammatical rule and the grammatical
rule is a general rule which is the
pronoun refers to the closest preceding
noun but this is not a universal rule in
the quran it's not a universal rule in
the quran and one would argue if you
look at the thematic context
actually
allowing the reference here to refer to
the human being themselves coming out
between the backbone and the ribs makes
more sense from a thematical perspective
because allah talks about first the
fluid then the baby then the
resurrection right so it just makes more
thematic sense which is perfectly fine
and this is the view of alkal to be
could be said this is linguistically
possible a classical scholar you know
someone who came way before what you
call modern science uh even
for example again
classical scholar came way before modern
science so you can't assume that they
just made this up because of the science
right so this is well established in in
the literature that it's actually the
baby and we know the moon is between the
backbone
and the breastbone and the ribs
in between right so that's not an issue
either that's the second opinion the
third opinion is
and this is an interesting one and
basically i think there are other
opinions but these are three major
opinions the third opinion is is by the
scholar maturity it's a classical
scholar relatively early
exegete one
which means someone who explains uh the
quran
he said this is
this actually means the male and the
female
so
here means
means the male it's a kenaia it's an
indication to mean the male because from
what we said
also means something that becomes hard
and rigid and
means the kind of breast bone so the man
is on on top of the woman usually right
sorry for being crude but but the
language here and this is a valid
classical view that is actually to do
with the kind of sexual intercourse
and during sexual intercourse that's
when the gaussian fluid spurts forth
right so that's an egg a kinaya and what
kina means is like an indication for a
meaning but for example when allah says
something like to free a neck
you don't only free a neck right
no you feed the whole human it means to
free a slave right so the neck is a k is
like an indication for the whole human
maybe that's not a great example there
are many examples in arabic language so
every single opinion that we've just
mentioned
is not a scientific error
and this is we've just done a quick
summary by the way and we could just do
a massive breakdown now now what's
important to understand the audience
needs to understand this
the quran is a trans-historical text
what does that mean it transcends
science
and we we shouldn't commit an
epistemological disqualification meaning
uh saying that science and the quran
have equal epistemic weight they have
this they have they have the same weight
of truth because we believe the quran
has come from allah and we have external
reasons other than this science stuff to
show why it's from allah
and we know science is a human endeavor
and if you look at the philosophy of
science you know
if you look into the problem of
induction you can always have another
observation that contradicts current
conclusions if that's the case
then what we know now may change right
obviously for some things it won't if
they're just direct observations but
when it comes to more complex scientific
conclusions it's a bunch of observations
you have to reason over them also if you
look into for example
um the different approaches to
understanding the weight of theories
scientific theories and science you have
realism anti-realism and instrumentalism
i would have to unpack this right now
on on friday but the thing is all of
them agree that science can change even
the realists realists believe scientific
realities believe that a well-confirmed
scientific theory with predictive power
um is a representation of the actual
state of affairs and it is a
representation of reality
but they it can still change
even richard dawkins one of the
evangelical scientists who believes that
darwinian mechanism is like the gospel
truth to explain biological change in
his book devil's chaplain he basically
says that in the future we may have an
observation and we could reject
darwinism altogether right so even to
try and even if there was a so-called
error in the quran which there isn't if
you understand the language and the
themes and so on and so forth it
wouldn't even be a problem it would only
be a problem if you commit this
epistemological disqualification right
so and this is very very important for
people to understand the final thing i
want to mention i'm not a bit going on
for too long it's very important to say
my dear brothers that the quran is a
multi-layered multi-level text when it
comes to it's versus referring to
natural phenomena and this and i'm going
to give you a teaser for people to wait
for
on friday the verses pertain to natural
phenomena have many layers of valid
meaning and each layer of valid meaning
can make sense to someone from the 7th
century 15th century 21st century and
31st century
even if the person who's reflecting on
the natural phenomena that the quran
tells them to
even if that person has
inaccurate inaccurate understanding of
reality and is a primitive understanding
of reality they are still going to
conclude the epistemic goal that allah
wants them to conclude which we
mentioned and this shows that the quran
is trans-historical and we'll give you
many examples inshallah to show that
there are layers of meaning that can
make sense to different people across
all periods of time and the quran is
purposely structured in that particular
way in a timeless way to engage with all
people to get them to affirm the most
important things which is something
about themselves something about how
they should relate to allah and who
allah is that's what allah wants from us
from that perspective and this shows
that the quran is timeless it's not it
doesn't have a structure or language
that is reflective of the seventh
century its structure and language and
style from the perspective of referring
to natural phenomena is in such a way
that can address every single person
from the seventh century and all the way
to the end of times inshallah
inshallah
sorry for going for you guys but we i it
was very important to unpack that so
just like here for everything
it's new friday here friday
yeah see you guys friday man it'll be a
live stream once again not pre-recorded
so we don't even know what's going to
happen but inshallah we'll bring on
hamza andreas sources one more time
bro before we wrap this up is there
anything you want to leave them with
uh i mean i think it's very important
for us to follow the advice of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam which
is you know the cure to ignorance is to
ask and learn
and we shouldn't basically have our own
intellectual and emotional baggage and
superimpose it on things that we don't
understand once we stand in that humble
space
and that's a spiritual space to be in
once we stand in that space and we stand
in the possibility that maybe my
understanding of the quran or my
understanding of islam could be
completely wrong
if you're in that space
then we're ready to roll
and we'll leave it with that
wrap it up bro
as well yeah let's do it
foreign
the prophet saw mentioned that the
bridge between belief and disbelief is
abandoning salah if you're struggling
with your salah right now well we got
the perfect solution for you and that
solution is the adan app this cell phone
we usually have it and is using us
instead of us using it but with the adan
app you can use it in perfect alignment
with your life the adan app is already
used by 40 million believers around the
world why because it caters to your
islamic lifestyle on top of this a lot
of times you get your eyes
the islamic calendar ramadan calendar
suhur and iftar times
hajj and umrah guide qibla finder
and much more for free so download the
addon up now